Traductor: Penny Martínez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Cuántos de vosotros habéis cambiado
de opinión de algo en lo que creíais
en la última semana?
Levantad las manos.
Muy bien,
cómo se nota que esto es TED, ¿eh?.
Bueno, los estudios no dicen lo mismo,
pero ahora seguiremos con ello.
Es normal que nos cueste
cambiar de opinión,
y esto se lo debemos
a un germen en nuestro cerebro,
un fallo en Matrix,
un error del pensamiento causante
del 99 % de las discusiones en Twitter,
y nueve de cada diez discusiones
con tu cuñado en Navidad.
(Risas)
Y es el sesgo de confirmación.
Suena duro, lo sé,
¿qué es esto de los sesgos?
Los sesgos son taras,
son errores del pensamiento.
Al final, los utilizamos
para ser más eficientes
y entender la realidad mejor,
pero hacen también que esté distorsionada.
Pero es que claro,
el sesgo de confirmación
es el que reparte el bacalao,
es el rey de la corona.
Así que el sesgo de confirmación
es que atendemos muchísimo más
a las ideas que confirman
nuestras ideas previas.
Y es que a nuestro cerebro le flipa
alimentarse de lo que ya conoce,
y rechaza mucho más de base
todo lo que sea extraño, ajeno,
o que confronte nuestras ideas previas.
Así que, amigos míos,
hoy vamos a ver una batalla épica,
el sesgo de confirmación versus
el pensamiento crítico.
Y como todo en la vida,
todo empieza con una historia,
pues esta es la mía.
Yo siempre he sido una niña
un poquito indisciplinada
y, sobretodo, muy preguntona,
pero muy preguntona,
y recuerdo en la escuela,
en todas las asignaturas
yo hacía preguntas, ya que
siempre me ha costado mucho
entender las cosas sin un razonamiento,
sin una explicación,
y por eso me frustraba
en muchas ocasiones.
Porque muchas ocasiones de mis profesores
recibía como respuesta a algunas preguntas
"Esto es así porque sí", y
"Esto no es así porque no, y ya está".
Recuerdo en concreto, con 8 años,
en la preparatoria de la comunión,
digamos que a mí la idea de Dios
siempre se me ha hecho un poquito
incómoda,
no terminaba de entenderla,
¿cómo es posible que un hombre
se convierta en paloma?,
y ¿cómo es posible
que esté en todos lados y no?
Yo me hacía un lío de pequeña,
y no entendía nada,
y cuando preguntaba
a mi profesora de catequésis,
me decía: "Porque la Biblia lo dice así,
y porque los caminos del Señor
son inexcrutables",
y ese tipo de cosas que se dicen.
Por suerte, en casa tuve más suerte
y recuerdo un día a mi madre diciéndome:
"No tienes que aceptar las cosas porque sí
o porque no, algunas te cuadrarán,
y otras no te cuadrarán
y no las aceptarás,
cuando seas mayor lo entenderás".
Así que le doy las gracias a mi madre,
por plantar la semilla
de mi pensamiento crítico.
Pero digamos,
que no germinó muy bien esa semilla,
y lo voy a dejar aquí
y no voy a dar más detalles.
(Risas)
Es broma, sí que voy a dar más detalles
que aquí hemos venido
a sacar las vergüenzas.
En mi adolescencia me convertí
en la mayor defensora de la Power Balance,
que si os acordáis era el timo
de la pulsera que daba superpoderes,
te mejoraba la salud y todo eso.
Yo iba ahí por la vida con una alegría,
lo que hizo mi efecto placebo, ¡madre mía!
Y también era
la mayor defensora de "El Secreto",
no sé si conocéis el libro,
y la Ley de la Atracción esta,
que te dice que al final el universo
te devuelve todo lo que das,
y que si deseas algo muy fuerte
lo conseguirás.
Pues yo era también
de ese tipo de defensoras,
y entonces durante esos años oscuros
de la adolescencia,
pasé de ser esa clase de personas
que piensa que si deseas algo muy fuerte
muy fuerte, muy fuerte,
al final lo conseguirás,
a ser esa clase de personas que piensa
que si piensas algo muy fuerte,
muy fuerte, muy fuerte,
pues lo normal es que te comas una mierda.
(Risas)
Y no pasa nada, no pasa nada.
El fracaso es parte de la vida,
y no pasa nada y se sigue adelante.
Entonces, después de esos años oscuros
maduré un poco,
y llego a la universidad, y digo:
"Yo voy a estudiar periodismo,
quiero descubrir lo que es la información,
lo que son los datos,
lo que es transmitir
con objetividad las cosas."
¡Decepción!, patrañas todo,
la objetividad no existe,
y eso lo aprendes
desde la primera clase de periodismo.
Todos nosotros
vivimos en una realidad sesgada,
sesgada por nuestras creencias,
por nuestra visión distorsionada
de la realidad,
por nuestras ideas previas sobre algo,
y por nuestros prejuicios.
Y no pasa nada.
Yo durante la carrera aprendí
que yo quería contribuir
con un pequeño granito de arena
a equilibrar un poco esa balanza
tan desequilibrada con nuestros sesgos.
Y ahí nació "La gata de Schrodinger",
un canal de ciencia, pensamiento crítico,
sin más pretensiones que despertar
la curiosidad de las personas,
sobretodo los jóvenes,
y hacerles pensar un poco.
Y desde que estoy
más activa en las redes sociales,
Youtube y sobretodo Twitter también,
me he dado cuenta,
de que nos hemos convertido
en esclavos de nuestras propias opiniones.
Somos totalmente esclavos en Internet.
En Internet todo funciona por bandos,
por packs ideológicos,
tú tienes que comprar un pack,
si te vas un poco,
si te quedas en medio, si discutes,
o si no compras proclamas
vertidas en 280 caracteres,
te quedas en terreno de nadie,
ya sea hablando de ciencia,
de política, de feminismo,
da igual, los excesos no venden,
no estamos hechos para cuestionarnos
lo que viene de los nuestros
y rechazar de base
todo lo que viene del resto.
Entonces aprendes eso,
y también que nadie está exento de eso.
Y como digo, nadie estamos exentos
de nuestros propios sesgos,
yo vengo aquí con un discurso
pro pensamiento crítico, pro escepticismo,
pero yo soy la primera
que si algo le da gustito a mi cerebro
lo compra de primeras.
Y un ejemplo muy claro, es algo que
ocurrió hace relativamente poco,
una noticia que salió
en todos los medios de comunicación,
y es: "Muere una periodista antivacunas
de 25 años por una gripe porcina".
¡Uy, madre mía!, yo leí eso,
y los antivacunas,
que son el enemigo público nº 1,
y es que es suculento,
se te van las manos al Twitter,
es que ya me veo twiteando:
"Premio Darwin 2019,
la selección natural hizo su trabajo..."
Es que viene solo, viene rodado,
y todos nos comimos esa noticia.
Y era fake, resulta que esta periodista
supuesta antivacunas era un tweet
sacado de contexto
de hace un montón de años,
que seguramente era sarcástico,
y que la gripe porcina ni siquiera
es una vacuna obligatoria en EE. UU.,
o sea, patraña absoluta,
y todos nos la comimos con patatas.
Así es la vida.
Y esto yo lo vivo, este rechazo
de primeras a las ideas diferentes,
yo lo vivo todos los días
en mis redes sociales.
Tengo un contenido que puede afectar
o confrontar las ideas o las creencias
de mucha gente en ocasiones.
Por ejemplo, en mi último vídeo,
fui a un congreso terraplanista,
a escuchar educadamente
las opiniones de esta gente
tan curtida en el terraplanismo,
pero también un poquito a refutar
un poco con la ciencia en ese congreso,
pero fui muy educada.
Estos comentarios que veis en pantalla
son de las últimas horas
para hacer la presentación, me dicen
que no tengo ni idea, burra, boba...
Sobretodo me llamó la atención
un comentario que decía:
"El lugar de las mujeres es la cocina,
no dándoselas de científicas"
(Risas)
Me sorprendió bastante, porque no sabía
que los hombres de las cavernas
ya tenían acceso a internet.
(Risas)
Me sorprendió muchísimo.
Cómo ha avanzado la tecnología,
es maravilloso.
(Aplausos)
Y este comportamiento,
que puede parecer irracional
o muy difícil de explicar
porque es muy visceral,
realmente tiene una base científica,
y sí que está estudiado.
De hecho, el psicólogo Jonathan Haidt
en base a bastantes estudios,
tanto psicológicos como neurológicos
como antropológicos,
ha sacado varias conclusiones,
y la realidad es descorazonadora,
y es que la mayoría de las personas
no buscamos la verdad,
sino reafirmar nuestras propias opiniones.
Y por eso tanto la política
como la religión como todo
divide hasta a la gente más racional.
Y él lo explica muy bien con una metáfora,
la metáfora del elefante y el jinete.
Digamos que el elefante es nuestra
intuición y el jinete es el razonamiento.
Ante una nueva idea que recibimos,
durante los primeros segundos
nuestro elefante ya he echado a andar
hacia una dirección,
y eso es ya en los primeros segundos,
el elefante toma una dirección,
y entonces lo único
que puede hacer el jinete
es un poco manejar al elefante
en esa dirección que ha tomado,
justificar y encontrar pretextos
en esa dirección.
Os pongo un ejemplo claro,
acomodaos en el asiento que esto es duro.
Si yo os digo ahora, ¿qué opináis
de dos hermanos teniendo sexo?,
el elefante, lo que dicen los estudios,
esto es un caso real de laboratorio,
dicen que en los primeros segundos
el elefante ya va hacia la casilla de
"esto está mal", "esto está muy mal",
pero ¿y si os digo que son dos personas
mayores de edad, que es consentido
y que toman precauciones, es decir,
realmente no pueden tener descendencia,
que serían los problemas principales?.
Pues los estudios dicen,
que por muchas explicaciones
y razonamientos que demos externamente,
una vez nuestro elefante,
nuestra intuición ha echado a andar,
el jinete lo único que puede hacer
es manejar a ese elefante perdido.
¿Qué le vamos a hacer?.
Y esto el poder lo sabe,
el poder sabe cómo nos gusta
alimentar nuestras ideas previas,
cómo nos gusta darle de comer
a nuestro sesgo de confirmación.
No hace falta ser conspiranóico
para saber o creer
que en las últimas elecciones de EE. UU.
o en el Brexit,
en ciertas decisiones políticas,
hay empresas de manejo de datos
como Cambridge Analítica,
que no sé si os sonará,
pero que se ha demostrado
que han utilizado nuestros perfiles
de las redes sociales, los perfiles
psicológicos de la personalidad,
para bombardearnos con fake news
y bulos orientados a que tomemos
una determinada decisión política.
Ha afectado a las decisiones del Brexit,
a las campañas de elecciones de EE. UU.,
se ha invertido más en propaganda
en las redes sociales que en la televisión
y esto nos da una pista
de hacia donde va esta tendencia.
Y en España, visto el panorama poítico
tan candente que tenemos,
¿es una quimera?, no lo sabemos.
Entonces, al final,
¿qué podemos hacer sobre esto?,
¿estamos perdidísimos?,
no, claro que no, se pueden hacer cosas.
Pero lo importante, es que sepamos
ser conscientes de lo que nos viene
y sobretodo lo que es la evidencia
y lo que no.
También nos afecta a nivel de la ciencia,
los bulos, la pseudociencia,
cómo corren por Internet,
parece que aunque tengamos
toda la información disponible,
nuestro pensamiento crítico no actúa
como debería,
por eso los datos nos dicen
que un 25 % de los jóvenes
confían en pseudoterapias
como el Reiki o la homeopatía,
que causan aproximadamente
unas 1300 muertes al año
por confiar en pseudoterapias en vez
de confiar en medicina que sí funciona,
que sí que tiene evidencia.
Esto es un problema
que va a muchísimos niveles.
Entonces, ¿estamos perdidos?,
¿no lo estamos?.
Yo no tengo la solución
a los problemas del mundo,
pero desde mi granito de arena,
desde la divulgación,
lo que intento hacer entender es,
para empezar,
que no hay respuestas para todo,
que es bueno que nos hagamos preguntas
y sobretodo desde los más pequeños,
que no pasa nada que nos hagamos preguntas
y que no pasa nada que estén sin responder
Y eso es así y hay que asumirlo,
y aprender a convivir
con los vacíos de nuestro universo.
También el conocimiento es atractivo,
¡el conocimiento mola!,
y es que solo hay que envolverlo bien,
yo siempre digo en mi canal que
es como darle la medicina a un gato,
que pones la pastillita, y lo envuelves
con algo bastante atractivo,
y ¡toma conocimiento!
(Risas)
Que a la gente
si lo envuelves bien le gusta,
y a los jóvenes les encanta aprender.
Y sobretodo,
hay que hablarles en su lenguaje,
sobretodo a la gente joven, hay que
aprender que el paradigma ha cambiado.
Por supuesto que está genial,
que desde la escuela y las familias,
fomentemos la lectura, leer libros,
todo lo que tú quieras,
pero ¿por qué no podemos recomendar
también que vean un vídeo de Youtube?.
Ahora mismo hay muchísima gente
haciendo vídeos de ciencia,
de música, de arte, de todo lo que
a una persona le gustaría saber.
¿Por qué no vamos al nivel
donde ellos están en su salsa,
y les damos lo que necesitan?
Ojalá cuando yo era pequeña
me hubieran dado menos "porque sí"
y menos "porque no",
y me hubieran explicado más las cosas.
Porque aunque creamos
que los niños pequeños no lo entienden,
estamos ya sembrado semillas
para que piensen por sí mismos,
y esto es muy importante.
Y para terminar, solo quería decir,
que está muy bien escuchar a los aliados,
alimentar a tu cerebro está muy bien,
pero lo interesante de verdad,
es escuchar a tus enemigos,
porque ellos son los que te atraviesan
las defensas, los que encuentran
tus puntos débiles.
Yo quiero saber qué es lo que falla
en las ideas que creo,
si tengo que cambiarlas
o modificarlas incluso.
Y no nos engañemos, la batalla sesgo
de confirmación vs pensamiento crítico
está perdida desde el principio,
esa es la realidad.
Pero eso no significa que no sea
una batalla que merezca la pena luchar,
porque es de la única manera
que seremos libres.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)